[Música]
gracias por continuar con nosotros y es
hora de nuestra sección cinco minutos
con esa campaña hoy rodrigo pri mi
jurista colombiano investigador del
centro de estudios de justicia y
profesor de la universidad nacional de
este país gracias por estar con nosotros
entre 224 y cuéntenos el abuso policial
registrado en colombia' violatorio de
los derechos humanos no ha sido nuevo en
el país el año pasado por mencionar un
caso diferente durante otra
manifestación un joven murió por un
disparo de la policía que mediase
requieren y cuál es el problema de fondo
que hay para solucionar aquí en colombia
justamente en cuanto a la violencia
policial
yo creo que uno de los problemas más
serios de la violencia policial tiene
que ver con que colombia tiene una
policía militarizada debido a la
violencia política que se vivió en los
años 50 y donde la policía fue utilizada
por el régimen conservador para
perseguir en ese momento integrantes del
partido liberal la solución que se
adoptó en 1958 fue a escribir la policía
a las fuerzas militares a las fuerzas
armadas al ministerio de defensa y eso
generó una policía militarizada que
tiene un concepto del orden público que
no es propio de una sociedad democrática
y tiende a reprimir violentamente las
manifestaciones de protesta entonces yo
creo que uno de los principales
problemas es este y se requiere entonces
una reforma estructural de la policía
para sacarla del ministerio de defensa
establecerla como dicen todos los países
o casi todos los países democráticos en
el ministerio del interior y que
adquiera el carácter de una organización
armada de su xii pero
sí y no militarizado eso implicaría
también cambios en términos del fuero
militar o la policía los abusos
policiales cometidos en relación con el
servicio son conocidos por la justicia
penal militar y la mayoría de esos casos
terminan en la impunidad en esos casos
deberían ser conocidos por la justicia
penal ordinaria y yo creo que esa
reforma que implica una reforma de la
constitución son el primer paso para
luego hacer reformas relativas a
reclutamiento a las políticas para
enfrentar las protestas etcétera
bueno pues justamente ya que habla de
protestas en este momento se vive en la
capital colombiana y en varias ciudades
una serie de manifestaciones que inician
de forma pacífica pero que terminan en
nuevos enfrentamientos con la policía ya
hay un saldo de 10 muertos y esto por
supuesto después de que el abogado
javier ordóñez fuera también asesinado a
manos de la policía como cree usted ya
nos contaba un poco que daría juzgarse a
los dos policías por explicar a la
audiencia la diferencia entre la
justicia militar y la justicia ordinaria
cuál es la diferencia en el resultado
que puede haber al juzgar estos dos
policías
la justicia penal militar es una
justicia que existe para garantizar la
disciplina militar esencialmente
entonces una justicia que no tiene la
independencia propia de la justicia
penal ordinaria que está integrada por
jueces civiles la justicia penal militar
de entonces debería juzgar únicamente
primero delitos de los militares no de
la policía ahí hay una distorsión en el
ordenamiento constitucional colombiano y
segundo debería juzgar los delitos
estrictamente relacionados con
violaciones de la disciplina militar
en ese punto la jurisprudencia
constitucional colombiana en la
regulación legal ha avanzado al decir
que incluso hechos cometidos con ocasión
del servicio por ejemplo como el que
estamos viendo en la pantalla durante un
patrullaje que este es el asesinato del
abogado por dos policías que durante
varios minutos le aplican
choques eléctricos en estos casos la
jurisprudencia constitucional ha dicho
que a pesar de que haya sido cometidos
en una actividad de patrullaje son tan
extraños
tan tan contrarios a la función de la
fuerza pública que a pesar de haber sido
comitiva en esas circunstancias deberían
ser juzgados por la justicia penal
ordinaria entonces este caso específico
yo creo que debería ir a la justicia
penal ordinaria pero ese es un tema que
puede suscitar muchas controversias
jurídicas y por eso yo creo que la
reforma estructural implicaría que hacer
de la policía realmente como la
constitución establece un cuerpo civil
pero entonces que no tiene que estar
adscrito al ministerio de defensa y que
todos los crímenes cometidos por agentes
de la policía sean cometidos por la sean
juzgados por la justicia ordinaria el
problema con la austera penal militar es
esa carencia de independencia y en
segundo lugar que la experiencia ha
mostrado que tiende a tener muchas veces
un espíritu de cuerpo y avalar este tipo
de abuso
pues agradecemos a rodrigo uprimny
jurista colombiano investigador del
centro de estudios de justicia y
profesor de la universidad nacional de
colombia por estar aquí en france 24 en
5 minutos con ustedes también les
agradecemos por su audiencia continúan
con más en real 24 punto com
[Música]